В студії «heute journal» з Гайнцом Вольфом
та Марієттою Сломкою.
Доброго вечора.
У Нью-Йорку Рада Безпеки ООН
провела зустріч для обговорення ситуації
довкола української атомної електростанції у Запоріжжі.
Безперечно, ситуація вкрай небезпечна.
Та на це і розрахунок росіян: атомна електростанція -
це місце,
де можна закріпитися та зберігати боєприпаси
без остраху масованого ракетного обстрілу.
Як це вже сталося з ними у Криму.
Майже ніхто з військових експертів не вірить,
що вибухи на військовій базі
спричинені нещасним випадком.
Далі - детальніше про один із них.
Тим часом самі українці надсилають чіткі сигнали
російській стороні
у соціальних мережах.
Про це повідомляє Лаура Барнік.
«У вас було декілька варіантів цього літа».
Таким провокаційним відео Міністерство оборони України
рекомендує відпочивати за кордоном,
а не у Криму.
Відео адресоване громадянам Росії.
«Ви обрали Крим? Це велика помилка».
Кадри вибухів на російській авіабазі в Саках -
люди тікають.
«Час повертатися додому», музичний супровід -
пісня «Cruel Summer».
Крим належить Україні - саме такий
однозначний сигнал містить відео.
Ця російська війна проти України
та проти всієї вільної Європи почалася з Криму
і має закінчитися Кримом, його визволенням.
Росія стверджує, що пожежа на складі
просто спровокувала кілька вибухів боєприпасів,
так би мовити, нещасний випадок.
Зеленський говорить про значні збитки та стратегічний успіх.
Лише за один день окупанти втратили десять
бойових літаків,
дев'ять у Криму та один під Запоріжжям.
Окупанти зазнають значних втрат бойової техніки
боєприпасів та на шляхах постачання.
Битва за тлумачення суверенітету.
Фото до і після показують: щонайменше
сім бойових літаків були повністю знищені,
решта - пошкоджені.
Російська пропаганда,
згідно з якою переважно все йде за російським планом,
дедалі більше намагається змістити акценти.
Російське Міністерство оборони, окрім численних відеороликів,
що демонструють збройні сили
в ході нібито спеціальної військової операції,
також інсценує зростання занепокоєння
з приводу безпеки атомної електростанції в Запоріжжі.
Останніми днями українські підрозділи
обстрілюють Запоріжжя.
Це акт ядерного тероризму,
що може спричинити катастрофу,
яка набагато перевершує аварію
на Чорнобильській АЕС.
Президент України також попереджає,
що Росія може спровокувати надзвичайну загрозу у Запоріжжі.
З місцевості довкола АЕС вже кілька днів
лунають важкі обстріли.
Але наскільки ймовірною є ядерна катастрофа,
якщо атомна електростанція буде пошкоджена під час бою?
Це має бути важка і цілеспрямована атака.
Як і решта реакторів того ж типу або віку,
реактори електростанції оснащені
залізобетонною оболонкою -
циліндричним контейнером.
Навіть якщо ця захисна оболонка буде пошкоджена
внаслідок обстрілу,
то це не означатиме автоматично,
що станеться ядерний вибух.
Атомна електростанція наразі ціла,
важкі бої в Україні тривають вже 167-й день.
Відмінність полягає у тому, що досі Крим вважався
практично неприступним.
Нещодавні події, можливо, перевернули перебіг війни
у протилежний бік.
До нас приєднується Густав Грессель, військовий експерт
з питань Росії,
який спеціалізується на
дослідженні військової стратегії.
Пан Грессель - колишній австрійський офіцер.
Доброго вечора.
Версію, за якої в Криму російський солдат
випадково запалив сигарету поряд зі складом боєприпасів
і тому все вибухнуло,
усі експерти вважають не дуже правдоподібною.
Проблема полягає в тому, що працювати
доводиться лише з гіпотезами.
Ви маєте відкидати малоймовірні варіанти.
Зокрема, малоймовірною причиною є займання
через кинутий недопалок.
Можна припустити, який варіант найімовірніший.
Те, що це було диверсією, також є малоймовірним.
Проникнути на базу серед білого дня дуже складно.
Немає жодних вказівок на те,
щоб росіяни шукали диверсійну групу.
Отже, причиною може бути або атака безпілотників,
або ракетний удар.
Варто зазначити, що всі наявні знімки місця події
зробили з дуже великої відстані.
Тобто вказати справжню причину та робити висновки
досить складно.
Я вважаю, що найімовірнішою причиною є ракетний удар
з огляду на тип удару та глибину воронки.
Тоді це були ракети великої дальності,
адже найближчі українські позиції розташовані
приблизно за 200 кілометрів.
Це не можуть бути звичайні артилерійські снаряди,
які досі використовували в цій війні.
Це також не можуть бути ракети, що доставили в Україну
США чи інші країни-члени НАТО.
Є кілька систем, які розробляли в Україні.
Це могли б бути прототипи ракет, які вразили
позиції російської сторони.
Згадаймо, наприклад, крилату ракету «Нептун»,
яка потопила крейсер «Москва».
Ніхто не знав, скільки цих ракет є, і чи вони взагалі
придатні до бойового застосування.
І ось тепер цей ракетний удар.
Україна могла використати ﻿й ракетний комплекс «Грім-2».
У будь-якому разі це неприємний сюрприз
для російської сторони.
Чи має це далекосяжне значення
для подальшого розвитку війни?
Подивимося, чи завдасть українська сторона інших ударів
у глибину позицій росіян.
У будь-якому разі це змушує росіян нервувати.
Для них це є проблемою, адже якщо кількість цих ракет
досить велика, -
вони мають значно більшу дальність дії, ніж ті,
які українські військові використовували досі, -
то безліч військово-повітряних баз, складів постачання
та залізничних вузлів
можуть бути вражені цими ракетами.
Російська сторона має думати про захист цих позицій
за допомогою ППО,
подальшу децентралізацію логістики,
розформування великих баз ﻿та поділ їх на багато малих,
щоб зробити себе менш уразливими.
Але хоч вони у такий спосіб зроблять себе менш уразливими,
швидкість постачань озброєння до цих позицій буде нижчою.
І це також є для них проблемою.
Постає питання: де російські системи ППО? Їх немає?
Чи це надувні макети? Як відомо, російська сторона
використовує надувні системи ППО,
щоб дезорієнтувати противника.
Але ж вони мають кілька справжніх систем?
Так, вони мають кілька справжніх систем.
Це, звичайно, досить дивно,
адже неподалік військового аеродрому
розташовані 2 батальйони, що мають
зенітні ракетні системи С-400,
які справді можуть відбивати ракети
та виявляти їх за допомогою вбудованого радара.
Але я думаю, що те, що вони встановили надувні макети, -
невелика вказівка на те, що все пішло не за їхнім планом.
Це означає, що російська сторона також боялася,
що українські військові атакуватимуть радарні пристрої
та системи ППО в Криму.
Є ще й інший спосіб захиститися від атак.
Ракети, які Україні надала США, розроблені
для виявлення та враження систем ППО,
мають пасивну радіолокаційну голівку самонаведення
та націлені на електромагнітне випромінювання.
Саме тому російська сторона відключає радарні системи,
переводить їх у «режим очікування»
та залишає увімкненими лише кілька радарних систем,
щоб противник міг виявити якнайменше цілей.
Якщо увімкненим є лише 1 радар, тоді як раніше було
4 чи 5,
тоді від 1 оператора радара залежить,
чи виявить він запуск ракети противника.
Наприкінці зміни оператор може бути неуважним,
а ці ракетні удари завдають за лічені хвилини.
Тобто він має лише кілька секунд, щоб відреагувати.
Якщо він проспав цей момент, а працює лише один радар,
то удару не уникнути.
Якщо підсумувати, якими є перспективи?
Українські військові спробували взяти ініціативу
до своїх рук,
так би мовити, змусити російську сторону
трохи понервувати.
Але чи вистачає того озброєння, зокрема, того,
що постачає Захід, щоб справді перейти у наступ?
Я вважаю, що їм досі не вистачає важкого озброєння
на багатьох напрямках.
Все ще є потреба в бронетехніці, особливо на Півдні,
де рівнинна місцевість і без БМП буде складно
просуватися далі.
Звичайно, ЗСУ також міцнішають з кожним днем.
Резервні підрозділи та мобілізовані частини
проходять навчання, зараз, наприклад, у Великій Британії.
Вони отримують дедалі більше техніки.
Тобто вони стають потужнішими.
Що стосується російської сторони, армія слабшає.
Але зараз відчутним є баланс між 2 сторонами.
Російські військові не дуже успішно просуваються далі.
Але Україні досі бракує вогневої міці, щоб провести
справді великі наступальні операції.
Якщо їм вдасться зруйнувати мости на Півдні, можливо,
вони зможуть знищити відрізані російські частини.
Але, на мою думку, великі наступальні операції
варто очікувати трохи пізніше. Можливо, восени.
Такою була аналітика військового експерта
Ґустава Ґресселя. Дякую за інтерв'ю.
До речі, сьогодні канцлера Німеччини Олафа Шольца
не так часто питали щодо конкретних постачань озброєння
для ЗСУ, як-от танків «Leopard» або «Gepard»,
як це було кілька тижнів тому.
На літній пресконференції в Берліні
обговорення стосувалися здебільшого
картини війни в цілому та її наслідків,
і насамперед фінансових питань.
Цією конференцією Олаф Шольц продовжив традицію,
започатковану Ангелою Меркель.
Незадовго до або після своєї літньої відпустки
вона детально відповідала на запитання
столичних журналістів.
І тепер її наступник робить те саме.
Докладніше з місця подій - Ларс Бонзак.
Канцлер без краватки, а сорочка не повністю застібнута.
Зустріч зі столичною пресою - завжди самореклама,
тож важливо не бути застібнутим, як-то кажуть,
на всі ґудзики.
Війна в Україні, газовий конфлікт, обвальна інфляція.
Олаф Шольц - канцлер у часи кризи,
але він презентує своє бачення
та каже: «Ми впораємося».
Ми зробимо все можливе,
щоб допомогти громадянам пережити ці важкі часи.
Я турбуюся про тих, хто у скрутному становищі.
Саме тому ми заявили, що хочемо надати
субсидії для оплати житла,
додаткову фінансову допомогу громадянам,
і зараз ми інтенсивно готуємо ці реформи.
Шольц зазначив, що не боїться неспокою восени.
Його мантра сьогодні, як і протягом кількох тижнів:
«Ми дбаємо, ми працюємо, і якщо десь чогось не вистачає,
ми це надолужимо».
Зокрема, йдеться про 3 пакет фінансової допомоги.
Уряд Німеччини надасть ще один пакет фінансової допомоги,
який допоможе громадянам та громадянкам
подолати проблеми,
пов'язані зі зростанням цін.
Шольц применшує фундаментальні розбіжності
у поглядах у коаліції.
Він не хоче давати оцінку взаємній критиці партії Зелених, FDP
та власної партії.
Дивує те, що канцлер з партії соціал-демократів
часто стає на бік міністра фінансів Крістіана Лінднера:
жодного податку на надприбутки,
жодного підвищення максимальної податкової ставки,
жодних заперечень проти
принципу обмеження державного боргу.
Я дуже підтримав те, що презентований урядом Німеччини
проєкт бюджетуна 2023 рік
не тільки не порушує правила Конституції Німеччини,
але і не застосовує винятки із цього Закону.
Шольц чітко висловлює свою позицію
щодо ініціатора більшості нинішніх проблем -
президента РФ.
Але наразі він ще не зважується
назвати Путіна воєнним злочинцем.
Президент Росії є відповідальним за цю війну.
Він вирішив розв'язати її.
І це жахлива, неприйнятна війна.
Це війна, яка порушує всі правила
та наші домовленості.
Шольц трохи обережніший, коли йдеться
про справу «CumEX».
Попри нові звинувачення, він спокійно ставиться
до роботи слідчої комісії, яка засідає сьогодні у Гамбурзі
та допитуватиме Шольца наступного тижня.
Два з половиною роки, неймовірна кількість слухань,
неймовірна кількість документації свідчать про одне:
немає жодних доказів того, що це хоч якось
було пов'язано з політикою.
Рейтинги партії SPD у опитуваннях падають,
конфліктів всередині партійної коаліції більшає,
але Шольц постає як канцлер Німеччини,
який не хоче бути надмірно прихильним
до власної партії у трипартійній коаліції.
Не можна вважати,
що після укладання коаліційної угоди
відбувся об'єднувальний з'їзд партій.
В коаліції три різні партії,
які також мають різні політичні програми.
Принаймні одна людина здається дуже задоволеною
після 106-хвилинної конференції.
І це сам Олаф Шольц.
Однак справжнє випробування для нього та його уряду
ще попереду.
А зараз Гайнц Вольф з іншими новинами.
Генеральний прокурор США Меррік Ґарланд сьогодні
прокоментував операцію з обшуку маєтку
колишнього президента США Дональда Трампа у Флориді.
Ґарленд заявив, що він особисто схвалив рішення
запросити ордер на обшук,
і тепер попросив суд зробити ордер публічним
через громадський інтерес до цієї справи.
За повідомленнями ЗМІ, причиною обшуку, що відбувся
на початку цього тижня,
є розслідування щодо урядових документів,
які Трамп нібито перевіз у свою приватну резиденцію.
Інститут Роберта Коха опублікував
свій новий щотижневий звіт
щодо ситуації з захворюваністю на COVID-19.
І дані свідчать,
що поточний пік хвилі, можливо, минув.
Проте ризик захворіти залишається високим
для всіх вікових груп.
Найближчими тижнями очікується,
що кількість госпіталізацій,
пацієнтів у відділеннях інтенсивної терапії
та смертельних випадків залишиться високою,
особливо вразливими є старші вікові групи.
Приблизно чверть лікарів думають про те,
щоб піти з професії.
Такими є результати опитування, яке провела
Німецька асоціація лікарів «Marburger Bund»
з-поміж приблизно 8500 членів асоціації.
Причинами цього є, зокрема, брак персоналу,
понаднормова робота та брак часу.
За даними дослідження, кожен 5-тий лікар
працює понад 60 годин на тиждень.
У середньому вони витрачають 3 години на день
на заповнення документації та адміністрування.
Спекотна та суха погода, що тримається вже кілька тижнів,
спричинила падіння рівня води в річках.
Під загрозою опинилися важливі водні шляхи,
як-от водний шлях річкою Рейн.
Зараз наслідки є особливо відчутними, адже газу мало,
для електростанцій потрібне вугілля,
а судна можуть проходити ділянки з низьким рівнем води
лише з частковим завантаженням.
Франція отримує підтримку інших європейських країн
у боротьбі з лісовими пожежами на Атлантичному узбережжі.
Комісія ЄС надала 4 пожежні літаки
у рамах Механізму цивільного захисту ЄС.
Крім того, на допомогу прямують
пожежні команди з Польщі та Німеччини.
Вони мають допомогти з гасінням полум'я
у разі повторного виникнення пожеж
південніше міста Бордо.
Зараз приблизно 1100 пожежників борються з полум'ям,
10 тисяч осіб були змушені залишити свої будинки.
Пожежі вже знищили 6800 га землі.
І ми продовжуємо говорити про наслідки спеки та посухи:
в Альпах льодовики тануть так швидко, як ніколи раніше.
Один із п'яти льодовиків Німеччини
цього року може розтанути назавжди.
Головна причина: червоний пил Сахари.
Найбільша його кількість осіла на льодовиках
у березні,
він поглинає більше світла, у такий спосіб прискорюючи
танення льодовиків.
Згідно з новим дослідженнями,
зміни в Арктиці також відбуваються швидше.
Студії засвідчують, що протягом останніх десятиліть,
у середньому температура там
підвищувалася вчетверо швидше, ніж у всьому світі.
Той факт, що в Німеччині в багатьох сферах недостатньо
інвестицій,
помітили не лише під час пандемії.
Коли раптом у вічі впало,
яка ситуація з диджиталізацією у німецьких школах.
Є багато сфер, у які федеральний уряд та уряди земель
достатньо ﻿не інвестували
протягом останніх десятиліть.
Залізничні дороги, автомобільні дороги, тисячі мостів.
За цих умов інвестиційне відставання
перетворюється на відставання в мобільності.
Особливо яскравим прикладом є віадук
на шосе A45 біля Люденшайду.
Про долю міста
та настрої у цілому регіоні
розповість Томас Мюнтен.
Автомобільний дилер «Meyer» у Люденшайді
вже понад 20 років стратегічно вигідно розташований
прямо на шосе A45.
До салону швидко можна дістатися через шосе,
уникаючи важкого проїзду містом.
Марі-Крістін Кнот займається тут продажами.
Бізнес йшов добре до грудня 2021 року.
Потім довелося повністю закрити міст Рахмедеталь
на шосе A45.
Відтоді все змінилося, постійні затори.
У нас однозначно стало менше клієнтів,
які привозять свої автомобілі
для технічного обслуговування.
Нам також не вистачає випадкових клієнтів,
які б приїжджали вдень або на вихідних,
щоб просто подивитися на асортимент автомобілів.
Завжди потрібно знати, як скласти графік тест-драйвів.
У годину пік у нас тут небагато клієнтів,
тому що якщо клієнт стоїть у пробці годину,
то й тест-драйв не принесе нам користі.
Єдиний можливий об’їзд на цей час
веде через центр Люденшайда,
через який щотижня проїжджає
близько 43 000 вантажівок.
Сьогодні туди прибув федеральний міністр транспорту
Фолькер Віссінґ, щоб особисто побачити руїни мосту.
У мера міста Люденшайд бракує робочої сили.
Ми помітили, що є багато людей, які звільняються,
шукають іншої роботи,
або подають заяви про переведення на інше місце.
На це, звичайно, впливає незручне розташування.
Як я вже говорив,
нам просто необхідна допомога та підтримка
у цьому регіоні.
Візит Віссінґа кілька разів переносився.
Однак міністр відкидає звинувачення в тому,
що він не сприймає проблему достатньо серйозно.
Ми працюємо тут з максимальною швидкістю,
цю групу управління проєктом очолює мій державний секретар
прямо з Берліна.
Ця група проводить засідання досить часто
і постійно доводить інформацію до мене.
У другій половині дня Фолькер Віссінґ
залучив громадян до обговорення.
Вони також незадоволені ситуацією.
Інколи, я просто хочу поїхати кудись ненадовго.
Можливо, колись діти захочуть відвідувати
спортивний клуб,
однак зараз це неможливо.
Я не можу витрачати чотири години свого життя кожного дня
на цей клятий об'їзд.
Якщо у нас зараз є якісь зустрічі,
ми тепер спеціально думаємо,
які ще справи ﻿ можна владнати,
оскільки ми рухатимемося цим маршрутом.
Тому що завтра-післязавтра я не хочу знову
їхати ним.
Будівництво триватиме мінімум до 2026 року,
перш ніж шосе А45 знову буде доступним для проїзду.
Багато хто вважає, що діє надто багато приписів
для будівництва.
Бо всі ніби підіймають палець вгору і кажуть: но-но-но,
ми там знайшли кумку,
або ліщинового вовчка,
або кажана.
За словами міністра під час будівництва необхідно
зважати на навколишнє середовище.
Проте, будівництво також має бути швидким.
Тут ні брак кваліфікованих кадрів, ні фінансові проблеми
не мають призводити до затримки.
І це забезпечується інструкціями,
які я вже ухвалив минулого року.
Віадук, як і його аналог у Рінсдорфі,
має впасти до Різдва.
Однак нові будівельні роботи почнуться
не раніше наступного літа.
А зараз Гайнц розповість про економіку.
З жовтня енергетичні компанії зможуть компенсувати
вищі витрати на закупівлю газу
шляхом стягування збору зі споживачів.
Зараз компанія «RWE» оголосила,
що не використовуватиме цей варіант.
Франку Бетмане, чому так?
Жителі Ессена користуються газом з Росії менше,
ніж інші громадяни.
Виробник електроенергії, безумовно, не перебуває
у надзвичайній ситуації.
Навпаки: компанія «RWE» має найкраще півріччя
в історії своєї компанії.
Вона отримала прибуток у розмірі 2,8 мільярда євро
до сплати відсотків та податків.
Компанія отримує вигоду
від енергетичної кризи та зростання цін.
RWE заробляє гроші в першу чергу завдяки
відновлюваним джерелам енергії -
експлуатацією вітряних та сонячних електростанцій.
Високі прибутки фактично падають на плечі компанії.
Завдяки своїм сонячним і вітровим електростанціям
компанія може виробляти електроенергію дешевше,
ніж газові електростанції, але їй дозволено стягувати
плату за дешеву електроенергію
за цінами газових електростанцій, що різко зросли.
Звучить парадоксально, але пояснює зростання прибутків.
Те що приносить прибуток - необхідно розбудовувати.
Сьогодні компанія оголосила, що цього року
інвестує 5 мільярдів євро у розвиток
відновлюваних джерел енергії.
Інвестуватимуть кошти у подальший розвиток
вітроенергетичних та сонячних систем,
а також у розвиток водневої енергетики.
Завдяки інвестиціям прибутку в енергетичний перехід,
виробник електроенергії також відвертає увагу
від неприємної дискусії.
Зокрема, вилучення частини прибутку в тих,
хто наживається на енергетичній кризі.
Деякі країни вже запровадили відповідний податок
на рекордну дохідність,
Німеччина все ще вагається.
Красно дякую, з нами був Франк Бетман.
Черговий нещасний випадок у парку розваг.
Понад 30 людей отримали поранення в Леголенді
поблизу Гюнцбурга,
одна людина у важкому стані.
За словами поліціянта, поїзд на американських гірках
різко загальмував,
а інший вдарився у нього.
Як це могло статися, досі незрозуміло.
На вихідних у Клоттені, земля Рейнланд-Пфальц,
жінка впала з американських гірок і померла.
Прем'єр-міністр землі Мекленбург Швезіг
відкрив 31-шу Ганзейську регату.
Це одна з найбільших у світі зустрічей вінджамерів,
великих вітрильників
і традиційного вітрильного спорту,
яка цього року знову відбудеться у повному масштабі.
Морське фольклорне свято триватиме до неділі.
У міській гавані ганзейського міста Росток, а також Варнемюнде
очікують на сотні тисяч відвідувачів.
Прикордонна зона — один із тих термінів,
які майже забули з часів поділу Німеччини.
«Край зони», про який говорили в Західній Німеччині,
стосувався радянської окупаційної зони,
яка потім стала НДР.
Ця фотографія була зроблена в 1988 році біля Лауенбурґа -
на кордоні між Шлезвіг-Гольштейном
і Мекленбурґом.
Вздовж Німеччини, від Балтійського моря до Дунаю,
на кордоні з тодішньою Чехословаччиною,
колишні центральні регіони раптом опинилися на межі.
Там, де закінчуються всі шляхи.
Хоча вони належали до Західної Німеччини,
однак життя там було інакшим.
Історикиня Астрід Екерт докладно описує це
у своїй книзі «Zonenrandgebiet».
Детальніше розповість Крістгард Леппле.
Міст Деміца.
Колись він перетинав Ельбу.
Зруйнований наприкінці війни,
він донині слугує символом розколу.
Тут, у районі Люхов-Данненберґ у Нижній Саксонії,
був глухий кут Федеративної Республіки.
Між Сходом та Заходом відомий як «прикордонна зона».
Прикордонна зона - це 40-кілометрова смуга, що простягалася
від Балтійського моря аж до Баварського лісу.
Велика частина території Західної Німеччини,
а саме майже 20%.
Ця смуга отримувала підтримку від федерального уряду
з середини 1950-х років,
щоб допомогти компенсувати раптове опинення у прикордонній зоні
та пов'язані з цим економічні недоліки.
Але попри мільйонне фінансування,
західний край зони був бідною частиною
Федеративної Республіки.
Прикордонна зона з НДР.
Аксель Карс згадує, що найтемніше місце Вендланда
було тут, у Блютлінгені.
Місце невдалих спроб втечі.
Це Ганс Франк, якого вбили у 1973 році,
тоді мені було 23 роки.
Лікар, який його оперував, був моїм лікарем.
Ця історія мені дуже близька.
Для історикині Екерт край зони -
це неймовірна кількість цікавих історій.
Найвідоміша з них - про Горлебен.
У структурно слабкому периферійному місці
здійснювалося захоронення ядерних відходів
з мільярдними інвестиціями.
Тут, на краю світу, народилася партія «Зелених».
Найтриваліша антиядерна кампанія
у Федеративній Республіці
почалася з району Люхов-Данненберґ.
На периферії виник рух, який дійсно вплинув на центр,
тобто допоміг сформувати
енергетичну історію Федеративної Республіки.
Верра, яка колись була річкою на краю зони,
десятиліттями транспортувала свій токсичний вантаж
із Тюрінгії до Гессена.
Видобуток калію з обох сторін посприяв тому,
що Верра стала однією з найсолоніших річок Європи.
Схід і Захід уперто сварилися щодо того,
хто оплачуватиме рахунок.
Західні німці спробували застосувати принцип
«хто забруднює, той і платить».
НДР завдавала шкоди, тому вона також мала
й очищати річку,
тоді як НДР сперечалась про те, що Західна Німеччина
має вигоду, якщо вони тут щось зроблять.
Тому їм також треба платити за заходи,
яких Східна Німеччина має вжити.
Зрештою нічого не вийшло.
Річка Верра донині така ж солона, як і Балтійське море.
Новий Монте Калі видно здалеку.
Величезні відвали від видобутку калійних солей.
Насправді це вічні тягарі.
Їх не слід ліквідовувати, радше навпаки,
вони збільшаться удвічі,
до закінчення видобутку.
До 2060 року калійні гори виростуть до небес.
Нові монументи в центрі Німеччини,
на території колишньої прикордонної зони.
Від минулого Німеччини рухаємося
у серце Північної Америки:
Скелясті гори.
Місце туги не тільки для американців і канадців,
але також важлива частина міфу про заснування США.
Ці гірські хребти треба було завоювати
на шляху на захід.
Наша американська кореспондентка Клаудія Бейтс
і її команда
подорожували Скелястими горами
для серії відео «Гірські світи».
Одразу після цього випуску, ви побачите її репортаж.
Побачимось завтра. До побачення.
Добрий вечір.
Через спеку цього літа,
ми прагнемо освіжитись у прохолодних водоймах.
Проте в стоячих водах нас підстерігають небезпеки.
Сонце нагріває поверхню води.
За температури води 25°С
водорості швидко розмножуються.
Ціанобактерії, відомі як синьо-зелені водорості,
також є токсичними для людини, особливо, якщо вони
потрапляють всередину організму.
Шкідливими вони також є і для риб.
Коли синьо-зелені водорості розкладаються,
зникає кисень,
що так необхідний для життя риб.
Дуже допомогло б зниження температури та дощ.
Однак, найближчим часом такої погоди не слід очікувати.
Сьогодні вночі ясно, позначки термометрів впадуть
від 18 до 10°С.
Завтра буде дуже сонячний день,
з невеликою хмарністю.
Тільки в Південно-Східній Баварії
є можливість грози.
Завтра на краю Альп термометри покажуть 23°С,
на Нижньому Рейні - до 34 °С.
На вихідних погода знову буде спекотною,
температура буде від 25 до 35°С,
на крайньому сході в окремих частинах будуть грози.
Із нового тижня південно-західний вітер
знову повернеться,
повітря буде задушливим, очікуються грози.
У понеділок температура буде від 24 до 33°С.
Гарного вечора.